[Music]
hi everyone its Alicia Malone welcome to
another episode of fandango's indie
movie Guide and I'm so excited because I
have three great films to tell you about
this week three smaller films that are
worth seeking out let's start with a
very creepy it comes at night just want
to talk
no one honest answers you have any idea
what's going on out there
this is directed by Trey Edward Schultz
who did the movie Krisha in 2015 which
was a very small very low-budget look at
a family dynamic now he has gone in a
completely different direction although
it still touches on family this movie is
set in the future world where something
has happened to the water system you
don't know exactly what but it's making
people sick
you've got Joel Edgerton as the father
Carmen and Joe go as the mother and this
brilliant young guy as the son the door
was already open together yeah
then happened that actor is Kelvin
Harrison Jr who is a big star in the
making and he starts to have these night
terrors these visions of people breaking
into the house suspicion and fear plays
so much into this film and it really
keeps you on the edge of your seat this
is a movie that I would say is really
unsettling it's a horror film but it's
not necessarily the kind of jump scare
easy scare kind of horror film it just
deeply deeply disturbing can't trust
anyone that's family don't get it tell
me Jenna
can I do
and it shows just what can be done on a
very very small budget trust me you need
to go and see it comes at night possibly
the best horror film this year another
indie well worth watching is called the
heroes rectified Bret Hayley Lone Star
barbecue sauce the perfect partner for
your chicken that was greatly Kanyon one
more lone star BBQ saw this does he
wonderful Sam Elliot he's so brilliant
he plays and access who is an aging
actor he's trying to come to terms with
where he is in his own career he's
trying to reconnect with his daughter
played by Kristen Ritter and at the same
time he has an affair with a younger
woman played by Laura pre pot I did one
film another that was 40 years ago
consider what said that achieving this
movie tell some truths about aging and
Hollywood it really made me sad and also
really thankful Sam in terms of thinking
about these classic movie stars and how
they age off and the age out they become
no longer relevant but at the same time
so thankful that there is a film that
exists which gives Sam Elliott a great
role to play where them remember for one
person were here it's not about the
immortality of any person
and my last recommendation is called
Beatrice at dinner a very timely movies
don't salma hayek this woman is a saint
it's like birds fly out of the sky and
land on her shoulder Oh likes no way can
I get another bourbon hunting
oh god this is Beatrice she's staying
for dinner
oh we were hovering I just forgive you a
part of this yeah I know you
Doug's famous who's been on the news I
don't know why I think I know you ever
danced in Vegas she plays a masseuse and
a healer working for a very rich family
and she gets invited to dinner it's a
very uncomfortable dinner and it's kind
of an allegory for this Trump era that
we are currently living in in America
just like this we took our children
thank you for having me when I first
came to the United States a long time
ago would you come legally yes ah pander
line was amazing so it was a fish so
buttery one of the characters
brilliantly played by John Lester is
this old white guy that has so many
prejudices and stern beliefs and he
thinks he's right and youth living in
his gated community and looking down and
everyone who thinks that you can hide up
here behind this gate and that
everything is going to be all right the
world does need your feelings it needs
jobs it means money it bees what I do
what doesn't need you Doug is a great
philanthropist shut up god I do I was
okay you're done sorry thank you very
much it is one of those films that will
have you cringing the whole way that it
was awkwardly brilliant and has so much
to say about society right now
definitely go and see Beatrice at dinner
if it is playing near you my
relationship with that guy paid for this
house I kind of feel like I don't even
know you you don't know me
three brilliant films this week all
hashtag Elisha approved so don't see the
horror it comes at night the sweet and
sentimental the hero all the timely and
awkward features as ever and as always
you can find me on Twitter at Alicia
Malone let me know which films you have
been seeing lately and I'll see you next
week
[Music]